die derzeitigen beauty karriere in
deutschland laden gar keine richtigen
beauty videos mehr hoch das was sie nun
hauptsächlich machen es komme die
youtube fehlt eine richtige beauty queen
und damit herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu dem heutigen video was heute von mir
heute hochgeladen wird schöner tag
hinter bis vorhin zu beginn schon gesagt
habe die derzeitigen beauty schminke
youtube in die zugibt beziehungsweise
die damit groß geworden sind die er
machen jetzt gar nicht mehr richtig
geschminkt tutorials und zeigen ihre
schminke und alles willkommen so vor als
wenn alle genres setzen auf youtube sich
irgendwie so vereinen und in die
richtung comedy gehen also aus gaming
comedy aus duty wird mehr comedy
auskommen comedy bleibt comedy aber ich
will das nun ändern
deswegen habe ich mir eine glas was ist
das eigentlich los box zu seinem
monatlichen beauty box im abo gefüllt
mit fünf duty essentials zum entdecken
und ausprobieren
ich teste heute schminke so sieht dieses
paket inhalt aus ich kann das einfach an
der seite hier aufreißen und dann da war
dann auch raisting
wir öffnen die boxen und gemeinsam meine
damen und herren
es ist daher ein paket damit du noch
schöner wird herzchen ilja das ist mein
manager bei studio 71 der das nämlich
zugesandt beziehen werde mir das ding
besorgt die sitzt nämlich in einem
gebäude mit glossybox ist es übrigens
kein toller klassen also mir ist es egal
ob die glossybox kauft oder nicht ich
weiß jetzt cooles oder nicht aber ich
teste das mal wir haben tatsächlich in
dieser box noch eine also wir haben
jetzt mal vermeiden wie sie gutscheine
und wir haben in der box noch eine box
einer ist echtes gold so schweiz
eigentlich alles oder direkt hätte mich
alter ich muss nachher immer mit dem
aufbau wir öffnen auch die zweite box
zusammen nenne ich wirklich neue box
oder die richter nach total alter pappe
ich nehme die sachen jetzt einfach mal
raus und gucken was da alles drin haben
also dabei dieses päckchen hier drin und
vierten mann
wir können ja auch von der tochter
das finde ich bin unfähiger mensch wie
man seine freunde ich mache das ganze
mal auf guck mir diese fünf essentials
oder wie viele das waren da drin mal an
und zeigt ihr euch jetzt 2000 jahre
später was wir jetzt quasi dieser
glossybox drin haben es sehr viel von
diesem krüssel zeug was einfach ein
platz stock war irgendwie genutzt wird
dann hier irgendwie so einen gutschein
von irgendeinem anderen produkt das
glossybox magazin wo mehrere beauty
youtuber rinnen und leute stefanie giese
wieso bin ich da nicht drin und die fünf
produkte die ich bekommen habe sind
einmal ein lipgloss dann habe ich noch
einen erloschenen material oder
irgendwie sowas bekommen dann noch eine
tagescreme eine hand und nagel creme mit
einem apfel logo drauf und ein schwarze
augen schärpen ich glaube ich setze mich
jetzt mal hier mein tisch und das ganze
so ein bisschen auszuprobieren ich bin
natürlich kein schminkt kanal also ich
wäre sehr gern ich glaube das wäre echt
ein lebenstraum von mir habe ich setze
mich jetzt mal erst mal hierher so ihr
befindet euch jetzt hier an meinem tisch
also können tischen die seele tisch
befindet sich zwar hier aber ich kann
auf jeden fall sitzen was ich gerade
vergessen habe ist dass ich auch noch
eine secret fleisch bekommen habe das
ist eine zu den cream und ich bin ich
weiß gar nicht womit fängt man den
anwendern in die sammelbox hier bekommt
also ich hab ich jetzt auch jetzt diese
längst produkte derzeit aus aufgegangen
mit dem an ich mache das jetzt wieso
einem youtuber wenn also hier schaut
euch das anders hier ist der keller von
der marke irgendwie krone ist da drauf
ihr super schön hier die farbe
hier zum glück ist der alte schon
überhaupt nicht irgendwie zerbröselt
gegangen sich den grad extra hat fallen
lassen um die robust dichten linie
angehe schwinden aber ich versuche ich
dachte man muss das ding in die nass
machen oder so aber erscheint
anscheinend auch schon zu zeigen
scheinen schein ich habe überhaupt kein
name das funktioniert nicht an anleitung
drauf ingredients mit rollator mineralöl
politbühne profil paar das hält sich an
ein versinken gift wie viel muss ich
davon auf mein finger packen reicht das
so ich weiß nicht wie man das hier raus
holt aber ich glaube ich habe dann
relativ tiefes loch schon gepackt oder
nimmt man dafür ein spiel die packt man
dass da wirklich helfen definitiv nein
andere seite schön damit auch alle unten
jetzt voll und ich habe es immer noch an
meinem finger eine ewigkeit später noch
immer nicht ab wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
euch auch einfach den finger abschneiden
dann ist auf jeden fall wenn ein ganzer
tisch ist einfach voll mit diesen scheiß
als alles klar
den appetit bewerten noch das dach von
427 mit einer stabilen 70 besitz produkt
das nächste produkt was ich euch heute
ich in meinem youtube video vorstellen
möchte ist der secret flash
was auch immer das ist mailand derby da
steht wirklich meint der ich weiß nicht
ob ich es lesen können aber hier steht
jested you smile endet also ich verwende
das produkt jetzt mal so wie es hier
steht mailand dapd georgiers produkt
apples of your choice blending as you go
for ski cross up tempo was für ein
tempel alter ich mach das mal auf da
haben wir jetzt nämlich irgendwie sonne
da ist nix drin aber ich kann bucht
drehen dann kommt nämlich franz mit dem
aus das war's es ist doch wenn ich die
anleitung nächste zeit nötig hätte
wüsste ich vielleicht sogar wonach das
riecht also hier steht das ist irgendwie
für die wangenknochen aber es riecht so
geil ich will es einfach auf die lippen
packen
wenn ihr was davon gewinnen wollt von
den denk für das land bei 140.000 sich
ein stück hier von dem passiert gar
nichts
so sucht sie anders aus keep me ich habe
keine ahnung ob das richtig angewandt
habe ich fahre das ding hier auf jeden
fall mal wieder ein und setzt den deckel
drauf ich würde dem university secret
fleisch wird auf jeden fall auf einer
skala von minus drei bis 170 eine
stabile 124 km/h schüler eigentlich kann
glossybox mich direkt das trottoir mein
gott ich hab den deckel vergessen
wenn ihr euch gefällt und jetzt nochmal
danke ich liebe euch das nächste produkt
was leute testen ist die
hand- und nagelpflege senioren mit
ekelhaften nägeln da ist ein apfel
darauf abgebildet das heißt ich hoffe
die riecht irgendwie nach abfällig fakt
davon jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen in
meine hände ich denke das müsste reichen
für meine nägel
vielleicht habe ich auch ein bisschen zu
viel genommen
es riecht nach apfel geschworen ich
hätte vielleicht tatsächlich nicht
direkt so viel creme nehmen sollen aber
ich wünsche mir jetzt einfach mal in die
hände haben definitiv zu viel genommen
schön verreiben ab auf die hände aber
auch die nägel vielleicht hab ich dann
morgen direkt sie mal so schöne nägel
wenn man jetzt die nächsten vier
weltkriege abwarten vielleicht sommer
trocken
wie komme ich jetzt aus meinem zimmer
raus zum waschbecken das produkt laura
naturkosmetik hand und nagel creme
bewerte ich auf einer skala von drei bis
17 promille mit einer glatten 100 miles
per hour mobile des paares das nächste
produkt ist dieses reinigt verwirrt make
up das sonst vielleicht am ende benutzen
deswegen schauen wir uns jetzt erstmal
noch den lipgloss stick von babor an
machbar aber nicht eigentlich schade
eigentlich dass verpackung der barbar
lipstick sieht so aus ist ein bisschen
goldenen
finde ich sehr schön gold mein lieblings
hat direkt nach pink und himmelblau
vielleicht schwulen pink ich mache jetzt
einfach mal ein dort ist sieht aus wie
ein roter kindergarten stift wo soll das
hinführen
das andere lippen den fand ich auf jeden
fall cool ist irgendwie nach einer
frucht geschmeckt hat irgendwie so mäßig
aber das ding hier sieht auf jeden fall
also man sieht dass ich anders aussehe
der barbar lipstick bekommen von mir auf
einer skala von minus 13 grad bis 70
grad ca so 220 grad
weil man bei der temperatur meine pizza
macht und pizza ist auch cool nächste
sache die wir uns anschauen ist die
tagescreme von ca das ist das ding hier
steht drauf tagescreme und schutz pflege
vitamin b3 und panthenol schützt die
haut vor umwelteinflüssen spendet
wertvolle feuchtigkeit und so eine
geschmeidige haut und ein gepflegtes
aussehen oder die luchse wir drehen das
ganze produkt mal offen und sehen noch
eine verpackung obendrauf ziehen das ab
und haben dann auch hier schon die creme
ist sehr großzügig ich kann davon
einfach mal was neben fühlt sich sehr
weich an auf der haut war eine das hier
schön und meinen händen und ist sich an
den fertigkeiten wackelpudding gebäudes
ohne spaß toll weil ich das objektive
nach hinten drehen bin abgerutscht ist
habe ich gräber an meinem objektiv ich
glaube das ist echt das einzige produkt
was bisher richtig verwendet habe also
ich pack's jetzt einfach mal an die
hände ich weiß jetzt wie die hände oder
fürs gesicht dafür was auch immer
gedacht dass ich habe meistens eher
trockene hände
deswegen business liegt auf einer skala
von 1 bis 10 bekommt dieses produkt eine
8 das ist einzige mal dass ich gerade
produkt wirklich richtig bewertet habe
bommel und zudem letzten produkte testen
werden mich diese mineral lauschen
ich habe das ding einfach mal auf packen
wir davon wissen was in die hand es
tröpfelt jetzt so leicht runter wie viel
davon bei bedarf in meinen händen und
werde das jetzt einfach mal meinen augen
anwenden
oh mein gott es klappt what the [ __ ]
ergibt echt schwer ist es geht gut weg
und spaß was mache ich hier gerade mit
meinem leben das was ihr von dem video
meine damen und herren ich hoffe es hat
euch irgendwie gefallen oder ich komme
deutschland da halte ich hab halt
einfacher studio 71 gefragt ob die mir
nicht vielleicht so eine glossybox mal
zusenden können und dass ich darüber
vielleicht video machen kann oder
irgendwie sowas überhaupt nicht sponsert
ich habe kein geld bekomme ich hab nur
diese glossybox zugeschickt bekommen
vielleicht ist das video ganz cool
geworden
hier findet hier oben ein smiley
eingeblendet werden darauf könnt ihr mal
einen kanal abonnieren und ihr findet
hier ein video eingeblendet wo ich mich
auch schon mal einen tisch gesetzt und
von galileo einen chemiebaukasten
ausgetestet habe es auch sehr witzig
geworden und grau channel abonniert mich
sagt freundin und klickt das video an